you are not going to believe this or you
are
and maybe that's really the problem that
it's very believable
yesterday joe biden's administration uh
made a major announcement
on vaccination this is not the
surprising part i'll get you to the
surprising part in a moment uh the
administration of joe biden
has been delivering hugely when it comes
to coronavirus vaccines
joe biden initially said the goal is a
hundred million doses in a hundred days
now at the time i said
we're sort of like already on track for
89 million so it's not super ambitious
but
then he doubled that goal to 200 million
doses in 100 days
joe biden then moved up the full
eligibility date to may 1st and
yesterday joe biden
moved it up even further announcing that
as of now
on april 19th there will be full
adult eligibility for coronavirus
vaccines
in all 50 states regardless of age
regardless of occupation regardless of
health status
and that is a really big deal we are now
giving doses to roughly one percent of
the entire u.s population
every single day about 3 million doses
per day
huge announcement incredible success
with the accelerating vaccination
program under this administration and
when joe biden finishes
telling the united states about this
great news
peter ducey from fox news when joe biden
finishes up gets up and yells at joe
biden
should the masters golf tournament be
moved out of georgia
what yeah that's what peter ducey
urgently yelled at joe biden after a
momentous
announcement with regard to vaccines and
joe biden handles it well we're going to
look at it
and joe biden's approach has been the
right one to this boycott stuff from the
beginning
joe biden says companies should do what
they want to do
i support businesses deciding what's
best for them
it's almost like a conservative position
but the voter suppression has to stop
check out the exchange and remember
biden's event was about vaccines biden
wasn't scheduled to take questions
biden is under no obligation to answer
stupid questions yelled at him by peter
ducey
but he does anyway despite the right
narrative the right wing narrative being
that joe biden won't answer any
questions from reporters take a look at
this
the master's golf tournament should be
moved out of georgia
i think that's up to the masters
look
you know it is reassuring
to see that
for-profit operations and businesses
are speaking up about how
these new jim crow laws are just
antithetical to who we are there's
another side to it too
the other side to it too is when they in
fact move
out of georgia the people who need to
help the most
people who are making hourly wages
sometimes get hurt the most i think it's
a very tough decision for a corporation
to make
or a group to make but i respect them
when they make that judgment
and i support whatever judgment they
make but it's
the best way to deal with this is for
georgia and
other states to smarten up stop it
stop it it's about getting people
you know in a sense conservatives should
love that answer these are
for-profit businesses making
you know the the apple of the republican
eye is the for-profit business
and it's a for-profit business making
the decision they want to make
and then dealing with whatever
consequences come of it period another
thing
joe biden does well there is once he
gets
out of the way the reminder that these
are private businesses deciding things
for themselves
he gets back to the core issue and i
think that this is something that
we should always be doing when this
issue comes up
which is the core issue is republicans
didn't get enough votes in 2020 or what
i mean by that is
they didn't suppress enough votes in
2020
in particular this happened in georgia
joe biden took georgia first democratic
presidential candidate
in a long time to win georgia two
democratic challengers
unseated two republican incumbent
senators in georgia
and so republicans are now trying to
suppress the vote even more
we have more than 250 voter suppression
bills across the country
that's also happening in georgia and joe
biden puts the focus on that that's
exactly what he should be doing
one bonus clip here joe biden after the
same
event is asked if he's spoken or met
with
federal reserve chairman jay powell
jerome powell he goes by jay
and joe biden says no and he explains
you know the fed is supposed to be
independent like understanding the
genesis of these organizations
biden doesn't want to get too involved
with the fed
and certainly isn't going to be telling
them what to do the way that donald
trump did take a listen to this
last spoken to the question
reserve chairman jay powell yet i have
not
can you say why i am not
look i think the the federal reserve was
an independent operation
and starting off my presidency i want to
be real clear
that i'm not going to do the kinds of
things that have been done in the last
administration
either talking to the attorney general
about who he's going to prosecute or not
prosecute
and under what circumstances or the fed
telling them what they should and
shouldn't do
even though that wouldn't be the basis
upon which i'd be talking to them
so i've been very fastidious about not
talking to them but i do talk
to the secretary of treasury thank you
all very
uh you mentioned much i was pleasantly
surprised
i've had my criticisms of joe biden so
far i've had my praise
biden wasn't even scheduled to take
questions he wasn't expected to take
questions he did
and he made some principles very clear
in ways that i don't think reporters
particularly liked
because it gave them nothing and joe
biden he almost seems to enjoy
toying with peter ducey who by the way
i mean if back when you had reporters
yelling questions at trump like that you
had fox and others saying it's
disrespectful
it's disrespectful to yell out questions
like that to the president they
they seem thrilled the right does with
peter ducey's questions and joe biden
handling them very well
i want to do one more peter ducey
segment next
because it actually relates to a really
important discussion about georgia
colorado the all-star game and more
so fox news smurf reporter peter ducey
tried to do a gotcha yesterday with joe
biden's press secretary jen
saki it failed so miserably that i don't
know
how he can respectably show his face in
the press briefing room again and to be
clear
he will show his face there again he has
no shame
but he should be ashamed and it seems
like it's a trend among the modern right
they're
unable to be embarrassed by their
self-humiliating behavior the issue is
once again major league baseball
which has quickly become the top issue
for fox news they've moved on i guess
from dr
seuss and the new game they are playing
is
arguing it's silly for major league
baseball to move the all-star game from
georgia to colorado
because colorado has the same voting
laws that they are protesting in georgia
now let me be crystal clear if it were
true that colorado had the same voter
laws as georgia
it would look pretty stupid for major
league baseball to say we're protesting
the georgia voting law
by moving the game to a state with the
exact same law
that would be really stupid there's no
doubt
it's not the case though and jensaki
knows it
and this goes really poorly for steve
ducey take a look
is the white house concerned that major
league baseball is moving their all-star
game to colorado where
voting regulations are very similar to
georgia
well let me just refer the few refute
the first point you made first let me
say
on colorado colorado uh
allows you to register on election day
colorado has
voting by mail where they send to 100 of
people on the state
who are eligible applications to vote by
mail 94 percent of people in colorado
voted by mail in the 2020 election
and they also allow for a range of
materials to provide even if they vote
on election day for the limited number
of people who
who vote on election day i think it's
important to remember
the context here the georgia legislation
is built
on a lie it's there was no widespread
fraud in the 2020 election
georgia's top republican election
officials have acknowledged that
repeatedly in interviews
and what there was however was
record-setting turnout especially by
voters of color
so instead what we're seeing here is in
for politicians who didn't like the
outcome
uh they're not changing their policies
to win more votes they're changing the
rules to exclude
more voters and we certainly see the
circumstances as different
but ultimately sorry let me add one more
thing it's up to major league baseball
to determine
where they're holding their all-star
game so gen saki was ready
and it's actually an even sillier
comparison
between georgia and colorado than
gensake makes it out to be
it's not at all serious to consider the
voting circumstances and laws in the two
states
the right is saying well colorado also
has voter id
they do but colorado's voter id is
what's called a
non-strict voter id law it's not
the obvious and outrageous voter
suppression attempt
that the georgia law is in colorado
voters can produce a number of different
types of id
including ones without photos if you
don't have id
you can still vote by provisional ballot
and at that point
election officials are charged with
verifying eligibility
georgia's in-person id requirement is
what's called a
strict law it must be a photo id
a photo id if you don't have one you can
cast a provisional ballot
but you then still have to bring a photo
id within three days
dramatically different circumstances but
here's the more important uh
issue the georgia voter id law at issue
is for mail in voting why are they
even talking about the in-person voter
id when this is
all about mail-in voter id now
next issue but but david hold on
colorado and georgia both have similar
numbers of days for early in-person
voting
that's true but colorado elections are
almost done completely by mail
early in-person voting isn't
particularly necessary nor relevant in
colorado
because almost everybody votes my mail
all registered voters automatically get
an absentee ballot somewhere between 90
and 99
depending on elections of voters use the
mail-in voting option
so yes colorado has roughly the same
number of in-person
early voting days as georgia but given
how few people use that option
given how accessible mail-in voting is
in colorado
it's incontrovertibly easier to vote in
colorado so
in total colorado is widely considered
a strong state for voter enfranchisement
for making it easier for people to vote
george's new bill
is a beacon of disenfranchisement and
then
just the last thing on this i do think
it's important to understand the
motivations
of the recent georgia bill because the
comparison about the
the rules is a fair one to make and as
we just did
the rules clearly are more favorable to
enfranchisement in colorado
but the georgia bill came from
too many democrats voting in 2020. joe
biden winning georgia in 2020
democrats unseating two incumbent
republican senators in georgia
in 2020 that's the motivation for
republicans but
you we republicans didn't see
biden wynn and two democrats defeat two
incumbent republicans in georgia and say
let's pass a bill to make it easier for
more people to vote no of course not
their strategy all along was to suppress
the vote this is why trump opposed mail
in voting they saw they didn't suppress
enough of the vote to win
and so now they're trying to suppress
more of it and we shouldn't ignore we
shouldn't be naive
and only look at the rules and ignore
the motivations the motivation is a big
part of it as well
and another complete and abject failure
by peter ducey
to catch jen saki in these very flaccid
gotcha question attempts let me know
your reaction uh about
uh all of it about the the laws in
georgia and colorado
about peter ducey's uh continued
attempts to make gensake look bad
whatever your thoughts are you can find
me on twitter at deepakman
we're going to take a quick break and we
have so much more to discuss today
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpacman.com
coupon code saves you 40 percent better
21.
the david pakman show is a primarily
audience
funded show you can sign up for a
membership at joinpacman.com
monday's bonus show breaking all sorts
of bonus show records the most
watched and listened to bonus show in
history i talked about my run-ins with
anti-masters during the vacation
i talked about my deep nose swab or
schwab as a former president would
sometimes refer to it
my recommendation is first thing to do
when you sign up at joinpakman.com
go to that monday april 5 bonus show the
matt gates story
is getting significantly more
interesting and significantly worse
for matt gates to catch you up a
republican congressman from florida
matt gates is now in the middle of
investigations
into very serious possible crimes
including child
sex trafficking every time gates speaks
to try to plead his innocence he seems
to
present new derogatory information about
himself he presents
new possible crimes that at least some
of us didn't even know he was under
investigation for
and we have now learned thanks to an
investigation from the new york times
that matt gates sought a preemptive
blanket pardon
from donald trump at the end of donald
trump's term
now in retrospect we know
that at the time that matt gates sought
this pardon
from donald trump gates was already
under investigation
we don't know whether gates knew that
was it gates
knowing he was under investigation that
caused him to seek the pardon from
donald trump
or was it gates knowing he had committed
crimes
and wasn't sure whether they would ever
be investigated
that caused him to ask donald trump for
a pardon
the new york times reports that quote in
the final weeks of trump's term
gates saw something in return for his
unending brown-nosing support of matt
gates that's my of donald trump that's
my editorializing
gates privately asked the white house
for blanket
pre-emptive pardons for himself
and for unidentified congressional
allies
for any crimes they may have committed
around this time gates was publicly
calling
for broad pardons from trump to
thwart what he termed the quote
bloodlust of their political opponents
justice department investigators had
begun questioning
gates associates about his conduct
including whether he had a sexual
relationship with a 17 year old
which violated child sex trafficking
laws
in an inquiry that grew out of the case
of an indicted associate
in florida now here's the key line as i
mentioned it is unclear
whether gates or the white house knew at
the time that gates was under
such an investigation it is unclear who
else gates wanted pardons
for he didn't tell the white house he
was under investigation
whether or not he knew it remains a
question
but according to the new york times
white house white house lawyers and
officials
viewed the request for a preemptive
pardon as a non-starter
that would set a bad precedent
the latest idea is when gates asked for
a pardon for himself
and others the and others might have
went away
to camouflage his own criminality
in other words if i know
that i have committed certain crimes or
maybe under investigation for certain
crimes but i don't want to call
attention to that
i could go to trump and say sir you know
as
he claims people do uh myself and a
group of my colleagues
are all going to be persecuted for being
a supporter of yours
pardon all of us and you frame it as a
preemptive protection
from like political prosecutions knowing
that
really the reason you want the pardon is
because you may have broken child sex
child sex trafficking laws um and
maybe you even know that you're under
investigation it's certainly an idea and
that is what some of
the trump associates are speculating
went on now ultimately
matt gates didn't get it as i told you
people around donald trump thought that
a preemptive blanket pardon for matt
gates
would not be a good look and it was not
something that donald trump ultimately
granted so there's a few different
layers to this
obviously there's the superficial layer
of
you know asking for pardons in advance
does not project innocence that's
someone with a guilty mind
and of course that's true the counter
would be
from the right that if you're
anticipating
bogus political charges you would look
for a blanket pardon as protection not
because you know you committed a crime
but because you anticipate that people
from the other political party are going
to come after you
that's just an argument right yeah i i
both sides have a talking point and it
sort of becomes just an argument about
the talking point
the the bigger picture here is it
certainly
seems as though matt gates must be
heading to a massive
historic downfall of epic proportions
based on what continues to be learned
every single day you know he goes on
tucker carlson to clear his name
he further incriminates himself he says
my
travel records will exonerate me they
raise even more
questions now we learn he was looking
for a pre-emptive pardon
at every opportunity it seems to get
worse and logic would point to this
guy's got to be going down
but maybe not quite frankly i think it
is almost as likely that this guy
has a shot at being a prominent
republican who knows presidential
nominee
with the modern republican party you can
never really tell what they will punish
versus what they will reward and
although clearly
all signs continue to point to gates is
in a
hell of a mess of trouble here how on
earth does he get out of this one
at the same time this is the republican
party that we're dealing with and they
are very quick to demand
consequences for those on the left but
not for those on the right
this is an area where this this is
almost like a critique of the rip of the
democratic party
sometimes the democratic party in order
to show
how they don't care who's doing the
wrongdoing the democratic party has
sometimes been too quick
to demand punishment for those on the
democratic side
in order to show how not biased they are
arguably the al franken situation is
such an example so
gates might end up never being heard
from again and resigning in shame or
or losing re-election going to prison
who the hell knows
or gates might end up as the vice
presidential nominee in 2024.
nothing would surprise me at this point
in time we've been following
whether republicans and trump abandon
matt gates or get behind him and so far
the approach seems to be don't say too
much one way or the other just kind of
try to wait it out and
this is something i'm not praising this
as morally a good thing
but republicans seem much more shrewd
in this way than democrats they're not
jumping all over themselves to condemn
matt gates they are sticking to
a com there's a political article about
this by gary fine out
they are sticking to a combination of
strategies that include
saying these allegations many of them
were first reported by the new york
times
that makes me skeptical that's perfect
for the media skeptical right wing
movement that donald trump created with
the meme of fake news
say listen you know we have to see
what's going on but
when the source is the new york times
i'm skeptical that's perfect cover for
for modern 2021 republicans to say that
uh others are saying straight up i
believe it is fake news
so down in florida there's a gulf breeze
activist named larry hettu
who straight up says i believe this is
nothing more than fake news i don't
believe anything coming from
mainstream media matt gates has denied
it all and that's good enough
for many of them other republicans
aren't as dismissive but they are
saying that the allegations are vague
it's unclear what's true
there's conflicting reports and
basically they're just kind of
sitting out of it one such example is
john roberts not the fox news reporter
but the chair of the escambia county
republican party
he says i wouldn't condone anyone having
sex with someone who's underage
etc but so far i quote haven't heard
anything concrete
and he says that i don't trust anonymous
sources from the new york times
um i don't know ultimately
whether republicans will abandon matt
gates and this sort of piggy backs off
of the the earlier story that we talked
about
uh regarding the news that matt gates
asked donald trump for a pardon
even that even now as republicans are
being presented with that fact but
listen
isn't the fact that gates asked trump
for a pardon a red flag that makes you
believe the story may well be true they
are still saying
exactly what i predicted they would say
in the last segment
if you know that with joe biden coming
in
and with all these so-called democrat
bomb throwers they're going to go after
people who supported president trump
why wouldn't you ask for a preemptive
pardon if you knew you were going to get
sandbagged with bogus political charges
once your party was out of power
wouldn't you try to protect yourself and
those around you
by asking for a pre-emptive pardon so
for every bullet point so far there is
a defense that they are coming up with
um
there is also uh the contingent that
without focusing on any of the specifics
is just saying
this is an attempt to take out
conservatives in particular districts
and try to replace them with democrats
um you know it's it's predictable i
don't think there's too much to say
about that it's sort of an
it's an indefeasible claim and uh
we will just have to follow and see
ultimately who stands behind matt gates
and who doesn't
my prediction is that you are going to
have
if indeed we learn more about the
specifics and it starts to look very
ugly for matt gates even uglier than it
already looks
i think you'll see a split you'll see
some uh
in on the side of uh on the republican
side
people like mitt romney although who
knows whether mitt romney specifically
would comment on this who would simply
say
matt gates should resign and then you
will see people more
under the umbrella of like the marjorie
taylor green lauren bobert types
who will stick with them they'll say
it's a political witch hunt and the same
type of stuff trump said about
every investigation into the things he
did during his presidency as well
a time will tell it's not looking
particularly good for matt gates
we do have a poll up the results of
which will soon be on our instagram page
asking what do you believe will be the
ultimate consequence or outcome for
matthew gates
you can follow us on instagram at david
pakman show
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners
and one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
slash david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him so donald trump suddenly
appeared yesterday for a total gong show
interview on newsmax
and it's funny it's sad it's infuriating
to some degree it's also just very
strange trump doesn't seem to be making
sense he doesn't seem
to be lucid he doesn't seem to have
clarity of mind in this interview let's
jump right into it
trump not even delaying for a second
jumping directly into the now
so tired lie that he really won the
election in 2020
and no challenge whatsoever from the
host
you will notice here being obliterated
you know the democrats are
looking to virtually demolish your
second amendment i said that was going
to happen
i wanted to ask you about you know the
election the election was a
it was a rigged stolen election
[Music]
if this would have happened to democrats
you would have had a revolution
they wouldn't have allowed it and the
supreme court
was did not have the courage to do what
they should have done because
these elections in the swing states they
didn't have anything approved
by the legislatures well that's right
yeah that's why i asked you earlier
that's why i asked you earlier if the
republican party had done
enough before the election to keep
some of these things from happening when
it came to
voting laws and voting integrity which
obviously all the states now are trying
to do their part with that but it's
causing a huge problem with a lot of
corporations and boycotts
well no republicans clearly did not do
enough
before the election in the sense that
they didn't suppress enough of the vote
they did not suppress enough of the vote
to win
in 2020 that's what they're now trying
to make up on lost time for
that's the genesis that's the impetus
for the georgia voter suppression bill
and more than 250 voter suppression
bills across the country in more than 40
states
listen now to trump uh answering it and
um blaming judges uh finally uh
president they did
actually they did they did and as you
know judges didn't want to hear cases
right you know they didn't want to be
responsible for
for this the judges didn't want to hear
the case but it's so simple
not only dead people voting not only you
know illegal immigrants
and all of the other things all of the
ballot dumps all of the things that
happened at three o'clock
in the morning et cetera forget all of
that they didn't get
approval to make all of these massive
changes and you're not allowed to do it
locally or even with local judges
local politicians yeah they should have
never been allowed and the supreme court
uh should be ashamed of themselves right
but not be
willing to take it on no push back on
anything
trump says that the supreme court
should be ashamed of itself and the host
says right trump says illegal immigrants
uh voted and the host is silent
illegal immigrants can't vote they can't
even register to vote
trump says dead people voted dead people
didn't vote it was widely examined all
these allegations about 10
000 dead people voting it was
investigated and there were a bunch of
buckets but basically what you had with
supposed dead people voting was
some people were accused of voting while
dead and they were alive a channel
i believe was channel 4 from the uk just
knocked on people's doors and said are
you dead and they said no i'm alive and
i voted
there were some confusions between
junior and senior
so you know like imagine david pakman jr
and david pakman senior jewish folks
don't do junior and seniors that's a bad
example imagine
like noah smith jr whose dad noah smith
senior
is dead noah smith jr goes to vote they
count it as a vote for noah smith senior
it's a clerical error it's still only
one vote they voted under one name just
the wrong name that's just a clerical
error
um there were people who were registered
to vote
and they died but they didn't vote in
other words
if you are registered to vote and you
die
you're not immediately removed from the
voter rolls but you also don't vote
so there were essentially you know that
that is just a ruse it didn't happen and
trump continues to repeat it
then this is where it gets really weird
the topic of major league baseball comes
up
major league baseball as we've been
talking about moving their all-star game
out of georgia and to colorado
over the voter suppression bill in
georgia and donald trump's answer when
he's asked
should we be boycotting baseball trump's
answer
is confused it's cloudy he seems to be
saying
baseball is inappropriate i don't even
know what that means
and that he has a lot of trouble now
finding baseball games on tv
which he's not interested in watching
anyway see if you can unravel the
meaning of this answer
it's all very odd so should we boycott
baseball
well i have you know look i'm just not
very interested in baseball
for the last number of years i think
it's not
appropriate you know you look it's uh
you want to find the game it's on
it's on every channel and yet you can't
find anything it's the weirdest thing
it's
used to be a nice easy thing to follow
uh and you know what i mean by that it
was on one network
and it was nice and good and beautiful
today you don't even know what the hell
you're watching so
i i would say boycott baseball why not
what is trump talking about here
it used to be one network and it was
nice
and easy to follow now it isn't
it's inappropriate so yeah let's boycott
it and i like how the host
laughs the host laughs like she shares
the experience of having trouble finding
baseball on tv
like what are they even talking about
does anybody understand this
sounds kind of like an old man screaming
get off my lawn
uh the nba you know it's on all sorts of
weird channels
nfl games they're no longer just on
sundays and i
can't find those baseball games anymore
really strange and it actually made me
wonder as i watch this
remember trump's rant about your you
know you'll have to flush toilets 10 to
15 times
if joe biden wins maybe trump is just
confused about how toilets work and it's
less about
joe biden and more about trump's really
confused because this answer about
should we boycott baseball
and trump says i can't even i have
trouble finding it on tv
it seems very scrambled so another
strange and unusual interview from the
former president
and uh these interviews seem to be going
worse and worse for him
they also seem increasingly less
prestigious not that fox news is
particularly prestigious
but you know the prime time interviews
on fox were replaced by
middle of the day interviews on fox now
replaced by middle of the day interviews
on newsmax it's all very strange and
something doesn't sound quite right
i have something really interesting for
you today
asa hutchinson is the republican
governor of arkansas
he's a 70 year old white lifelong
conservative dude right he's not the
picture of progressivism
but there is one area in which asa
hutchinson's
traditional conservatism overlaps
with progressive social ideas and it's
on small
l libertarianism okay the progressive
view being
let people do what they want and be who
they are
without interference from the government
particularly
when there are issues where we talk to
medical experts we don't need
people like asa hutchinson telling us
what to do overlapping with the
conservative view
which is government should only be
involved
in anything when there's really a
specific reason for
government involvement it's not
government should take a position on
everything
it's we shouldn't even be involved in a
lot of things unless there's a really
good reason to do so
government doesn't have to have a say in
everything that's exactly the reasoning
for why republican governor asa
hutchinson
vetoed a bill from the arkansas house
and senate which would
ban gender affirming treatments for
transgender minors in the state of
arkansas
now unfortunately asa hutchinson's veto
was overridden by the state house and
senate
but hutchinson has made his view clear
the bill is too extreme
and the new law will have devastating
repercussions for transgender
youth who are already undergoing various
medical treatments
in passing the save adolescence from
experimentation act this is what they're
calling it
arkansas became the first state to pass
a bill
restricting access to gender affirming
health care for anyone under 18
even with parental consent other states
have similar bills
working their way through legislatures
so hutchinson goes on tucker carlson's
show last night
it's actually fascinating to watch
because the governor explains
how his conservatism is what led him to
veto the bill
and tucker just looks confused he does
his confused face he seems unable to
understand it or unwilling
and at first tucker won't even let the
governor answer the question take a look
there's in the most sensitive issues and
so sure
why are we regulating the behavior of
children at all if we're allowing
children to decide and by the way
i read a study today that showed the
overwhelming majority of kids
who do not take life-altering hormones
in the end decide not to quote
transition to a new sex
so there's a lot going on here but i'm
asking as
a conservative you just incited invoked
ronald reagan as if he were for chemical
castration of children
what other behavior should we not use
the power of the state to regulate among
kids
seriously well you debate it every time
look tucker you want to keep talking you
want me to answer a question
well thank you and so whenever you
whether it's
it's beer for minors these are all
issues that you have to address the
legislature you make judgment calls on
it
but we also try to restrain ourselves as
conservatives and say we don't have to
be involved in every issue
and if you want to broaden the party if
you want to get back to the principles
then let's at least think through in a
reasoned way as to whether this is the
right bill to interfere
with parents and doctors decisions on a
health care matter as you pointed out
has does not have thorough research in
every area
this is an actual conservative principle
we don't need to be involved in every
issue
now i am not praising this because i
would agree with him
about every issue in which the
government should or should not be
involved
but the republican party has abandoned
this supposed value
anti-wokeness owning the libs guns on
the house floor
none of this stuff is real traditional
conservatism as it used to exist
recognizing that they don't have to be
involved in every issue
even if they don't like what some people
are doing
that is a conservative value let's
continue
and so i yield to that and whenever you
look at this bill it might
yield to the lack of research really
quick 10 years ago if somebody had said
hey asa hutchinson you're going to be
governor of arkansas
and you're going to veto a bill that
would have protected children from
chemical
castration what do you think you would
have said
well just like i said today if you're
talking about a reassignment surgery i
would have
signed that bill in a minute but
whenever you're talking about
maybe less than 200 kids in arkansas
that's currently on
hormone treatment and they are
immediately cut off
without having a grandfather clause in
this legislation i don't think that's
treating those kids or their parents or
their
health care providers fairly or equally
all right that's the conservative
position governor thanks i appreciate
you coming on
tucker here is ridiculing the idea that
this is a conservative position
that asa hutchinson is uh espousing
but it is hutchinson says the science is
unclear on some of this
that's absolutely true it is without a
doubt true that the science
is not yet clear about the benefits and
risks of adolescent
um uh transitions that maybe with or
without medication with or without
surgery
it's undeniable i'm not even taking a
position on that
it is still early in that process of
figuring out
what is good and what is not so good for
different people
but if that's the case you don't say
well then government decides
that would be more reason to say let's
leave this in the medical science
community
even though it's still being researched
medical science knows more than asa
hutchinson
that's the important principle here
and if it's as unclear as asa hutchinson
says
and it's still something being
investigated
why would politicians decide instead of
doctors it makes no sense
it is the conservative position and
unless there's a really good reason
and a body of evidence for politicians
to get involved
just stay the hell out of it and that is
exactly what asa hutchinson is saying
it's an actual conservative position and
tucker's
confusion about it or maybe feigned
confusion that's really anger
confirms to us once again that tucker
carlson's faux populism
there's nothing conservative about it
fundamentally nicely done
by asa hutchinson and um as far
as you know when as far as the science
as far as what should or shouldn't be
legal or at what age or with or without
parental consent
these are things that the medical
community
will figure out and is researching we
don't need
imagine the what is conservative about
thinking that you need the arkansas
state legislature and state senate
involved in something with which medical
science
is now exploring and researching it's
delusional
and it's certainly not conservative let
me know your thoughts i will take a
quick break and be right back
the david pakman show is now on
instagram at david pakman show you can
check out
behind the scenes pictures memes
shots of the studio shots of what pat
does
all day very very concerning to a lot of
people all of that and more on the david
pakman show
instagram account at david pakman show
so-called libertarian
republican senator rand paul is now
calling
for republicans to boycott coca-cola
i know i know why is he doing this
well because coca-cola expressed an
opinion
that the georgia voter suppression bill
is bad
here is rand paul saying it on fox news
on sunday take a look but my point is
yeah if they want to boycott us why
don't we boycott them
this is the only thing that will teach
them lesson if coca-cola wants to only
operate in democrat states and wants
only democrats to drink coca-cola
god love them we'll see how well they do
when half of the country quits drinking
coca-cola
when half the country quits using delta
now of course
half the country won't quit flying delta
and half the country won't quit drinking
coca-cola
partially because people are addicted to
coca-cola but partially because these
culture issues only play big in
some circles and most americans don't
care about them
here's another one republican senate
minority leader
just still gives me great pleasure to
say senate minority leader mitch
mcconnell
he says corporations should stay out of
politics
it's unbelievable i know take a look and
i found it completely discouraging to
find a bunch of
corporate ceos getting in the middle of
politics
my advice to the corporate ceos of
america is to stay out of politics
so the question for mitch mcconnell is
should they also stay out of politics by
not making any political donations
because
if money is speech you're really
speaking either way
and later mitch mcconnell was asked
about her and he said oh no no no i'm
not talking about political donations
but think about that i mean think about
the
the hypocrisy if money is speech
when companies make political donations
they are speaking
they are giving political opinions by
donating money
to one or the other or both parties or
neither
but he says corporations need to shut up
except the money which is speech
according to them
that that doesn't need to stop um
these people are the biggest hypocrites
at every single level and look
look at the number of double standards
that there are
when it's chick-fil-a with a political
statement they like
it's speech corporations are entitled to
speak
they shouldn't be punished for having
opinions the people saying boycott
chick-fil-a are the ones that are in the
wrong
when it's coca-cola with an opinion they
don't like
the view now becomes corporate ceos
should shut up and stay out of politics
but not when it comes to political
donations
where money is speech in that case mitch
mcconnell wants them very much
in politics donating to him
they're against cancel culture they're
against boycotts
when it's of fox news advertisers but
then they
cheer when fox news runs a crawl
with a list of companies that took the
wrong position
on voting laws which we're going to look
at in the next segment
who is more pathetic and hypocritical
than these people now i'm going to make
a statement today
i am committed to not
changing my soda consumption in any way
as a result of this
i have not had soda for like a decade
other than the occasional foreign coke
yes foreign coke sweetened not with corn
syrup but with sugar
i've probably had five foreign cokes in
latin america and europe over the last
10 years
otherwise i am committed to not making
any changes one way or the other to my
non-existent soda consumption as a
result of this now just one other really
funny thing
about this entire thing they might be
saying boycott coke without actually
having any intention or plan to do it
case in point new picture of donald
trump at his new office
and his new desk in florida or florida
depending on your
your preference new picture has been
published if you look at it carefully
you can actually see a coke bottle
hidden behind donald trump's phone so
even
their stated boycotts uh they may not
abide by
because they actually just like the
product how ridiculous are these people
completely and totally pathetic
abandoning their stated values
they don't really care it's all about
avoiding policy
and fighting cultural issues and fox
news is now in on it too let's talk
about that next
it is truly stunning but not
surprising how quickly
the biggest anti-cancel culture
activists
have gone full cancel culture they seem
to have no shame
they seem to have no even understanding
of what they are doing
and it is amazing how quickly the
biggest advocates
for never regulating business are now
saying to businesses
what they can and should say and when
they should just
shut their mouths and say nothing fox
and friends
has been just one data point fox news in
general
has been just one data point of the
types that have been railing against
so-called cancel culture for months
freedom of speech is under attack
they want to cancel easter they want to
cancel prayer they want to cancel dr
seuss people and businesses are being
punished by the left for wrong think
and wrong speech and all of this stuff
and since the georgia voter suppression
bill
has led to vir various organizations and
businesses to say simply
we'd rather not do business with georgia
in georgia we're going to go somewhere
else instead
everybody has reversed donald trump
released his list of companies to
counter
boycott rand paul says boycott coca-cola
mitch mcconnell says corporate ceos
should shut up about politics but keep
donating to me
and now fox news isn't even pretending
anymore here is a segment in which they
ran a list of companies that have
criticized the georgia law
on a crawl up the screen and you will
notice
that what they are criticizing here
is criticizing speech speech
in which you criticize is just talking
it's speech and they are saying
punish these businesses for criticizing
which is another word for
speaking check out this clip let's look
at the list
other companies and organizations that
have criticized the georgia voting law
now we're not saying that they're
boycotting
but they're criticizing and that's where
these things sometimes can start i say
sometimes we can't tell the future
but you know from what what you're
saying atlanta
all of georgia can be hurt by these
decisions and i want to point out
who did their homework on denver who did
their homework on colorado compare the
voter laws
i don't know guys i'm starting to think
that the right may not be sincere
about their supposed values of free
speech and of businesses doing what they
want without punishment and
being against cancellation and being
against boycotts
it's almost like they only advocate for
these values when it's convenient
and when it doesn't conflict with
whatever else they want and then they
will quickly abandon the values when it
does
and by the way their list is now
way bigger than any list i've ever seen
on the left which is like a
it's an insignificant but also
compelling little detail
this is a list that the left can use
though if you want i'm not saying do
this but you could
if you want you could look at that list
that fox news
crawled and you could contact those very
same companies
and say i support what you were doing
in speaking out against voter
suppression that's
speech you could use to counter their
speech
meant to counter the corporate speech
which is part of the fight against voter
suppression
consider how absurd it is when
people get boycotts going against fox
news
advertisers fox news hosts and right
wingers and trump and all
they say that's bad that's cancel
culture
but then the next thing you know fox
news is running a crawl
with a list of companies they don't like
that they want people to target these
people are pathetic and this is why
you know i i don't necessarily want to
open up this can of worms right now
but some of you know that i've done
interviews before with uh
sometimes it's with enlightened
centrists sometimes it's with anti-woken
sometimes it's just random callers when
we open up the phone lines
who will say david you're not talking
enough and being clear about
your principle what is your principle
about abcd
and as i've pointed out many times i
have no issue talking about principles
but there's two problems
with the talking only about principles
one
you end up in a philosophical
theoretical black hole
that does very little to help you figure
out real world situations
most real world situations aren't
resolved
in any sensible way by just saying
let me run the facts through my
principles and then i get an answer
the hard work actually is understanding
how to balance
values principles and the facts on the
ground that's really the work and so i
don't
find it particularly i don't find it
innovative i don't find it productive
and i don't find it particularly
enlightened
to sort of recede from the facts of
what's going on on this planet
and to just have conversations about
principles and values i think it helps
you solve very very little and i've said
that before
but the more i don't know about more
important but the more
pressing reason why just the discussions
about principles
in the absence of of reality uh
is a waste of time is that people will
very quickly abandon their principles
anyway these the principle of free
speech and of being against business
regulation
look at how quickly it's gone into the
trash trump has released the list of
companies to boycott
fox news is running a crawl rand paul
excuse me says boycott coca-cola mitch
mcconnell says corporate ceos should
shut up even though his value
is of free speech and corporations doing
whatever they want
why engage with people on values and
principles
when they only stand behind those to the
point that it is politically convenient
and when it's not they abandoned them as
well
all of these people are pathetic they're
all bad faith actors
and in some cases ignorant it's also it
can be a combination of the two
we have a voicemail number you can call
any time of day 2192 david p
a very important issue that i am glad to
have the chance to address
vaccine passports take a listen to this
voicemail
hey david is anyone of any political
clout
actually talking about instituting
vaccine passports
we keep hearing people being worried
that they may require these things but
who's actually going to
implement this yeah okay so this is a
very important question
number one we are increasingly
hearing that the united states doesn't
plan to institute
some kind of a mandatory
government-level
vaccine passport if individual
businesses want to require vaccination
if schools want to require vaccination
if colleges want to require vaccinations
there would be nothing new or unique
about that
i had a list of vaccinations i had to
have to go to college
um that's it's just it's simply not new
or controversial in any way if other
okay if the u.s wants to institute a
vaccination
requirement for people coming from other
countries
there would be nothing controversial
about that and also if other countries
want to say
if you're an american and you want to
come do tourism where we are in our
country
you need the following vaccines that
already exists
you are required to have a yellow fever
vaccine to travel to some south american
countries and to some african countries
it's been going on for decades
i didn't hear don jr talking about it or
people calling it the mark of the beast
or whatever
uh to go to saudi arabia i believe
during i believe it's during the hajj
maybe it's year round
you need a meningococcal vaccine okay
i could go on and on this isn't new
it's not controversial the term vaccine
passport is admittedly a new way to
refer to this
but we have had globally depending on
what school you're going to or what
country you want to travel to
a whole variety of required vaccines you
don't have to get the vaccine
you're just required to have it if you
want to do this thing
countries will have rules about who can
go to their country that's always been
the case much the same way that trump
did his
majority muslim country travel ban he
could have done a vaccination
requirement
or the state department could so this
entire issue
is completely blown out of proportion
there is nothing controversial here
proof of vaccination has been around as
a requirement for different elements of
society
traveling state departments domestically
college etc
for decades and this is another one of
these creating an issue
out of nothing listen if uh delta says
you need a vaccine to fly
and you don't want to get the vaccine
then just don't fly delta figure out
some other way to do it drive
if you can or fly an airline that
doesn't require it
if your kid's college or your college
says
here's the list of vaccines and it now
includes the coveted vaccine
uh wonder to yourself or ask yourself
why is the list now not okay but it was
when it didn't include the covet 19
vaccine
it's a pathetic distraction i wish they
would stop they're making themselves
look stupid there's nothing
controversial here
we have a great bonus show for you today
china is creating its own digital
currency
this is the first major economy that is
doing this we're going to talk about it
and the implications
there are more and more calls to boycott
yes boycott
beijing's olympics and there are also
concerns about retaliation from china
and we now have a situation in the
united states where half
50 percent of new covet cases are coming
from just
five u.s states which states are they
and why is it that they are so heavily
concentrated
in just these five states all
very important issues that we will
discuss on today's
bonus show two ways to get access to the
bonus show real easy
become a member at joinpacman.com the
coupon code better21 is available if you
want it
become a patron at patreon.com
davidpakmanshow if you're already a
member you can also become a patron
if you're already a patron you can also
become a member you are allowed to
double dip
for now that is not against the law
although
we're keeping a close eye on it i will
see you on today's bonus